this is under all ideal circumstances
exactly the railroad exactly the right
speed and so on but this isn't always
the case okay so this is case one
without friction now we're going to work
it out with friction okay I need to rub
this off so everyone's got this diagram
by want to leave that there and we're
going to jessica cirio yeah it's I told
me tell me what supposed speed i'm
supposed to go around and then puppy my
being or in fact I having it up or I'm
Leslie well if i go around at this speed
what will the forces be now while I'm
doing this I'd like you to draw a new
diagram but this time draw the sky
without all the resolution stuff on it
just draw me the normal and then I want
you to tell me where we'll friction be
going where will it be facing okay I'm
not going to just yet there are actually
a few different places I could put it at
least two I want you to draw a diagram
first don't put any force resolution
stuff on it this diagram will need two
extra diagrams to resolve those quarters
okay so draw your banked track there's
not much of my diagram just yet I'm
about to put on friction force ok now
the friction force remember it's about
its I mean it's on the ground it's on
the ground right you can further make
you go from where your perspective is
either for you left or right left or
right so therefore once I baked the
track it's either gonna go up the hill
or down the hill right depending on how
fast I'm going no I'm now picking a
direction for this just on my diagram I
want to put the positive direction of
the positive access what do you think
makes sense as the direction for the
positive axis hmm ok all right now in
reality you really can choose either way
that you really can i prefer to put the
force of friction off the hill and i'll
give you two reasons for that ok um
battle-ax this is called el for lateral
force because it goes sideways relative
to the car
which is laterals a fancy word for
sideways so far we've been defining in
into the center as negative right I
think that make sense like negative is
smaller numbers over this way positive
means you're going out okay I'm you'll
find many textbooks to find it exactly
the other way around but you will find
everything just come down the wash just
all that maybe your signs are different
and you will interpret them in the
opposite way ok so I'm going to have L
facing up that way we're going to get to
resolve its forces in a moment let's
have a look at this actual concrete
example and use all of this results we
just showed on the left if you've got a
highway it's going to have to take a
turn around a radius of a kilometer we
want it to be designed for 120 km/h what
is the angle of the embankment that's
the first question so what you have a
look at what we have established over
here what am I going to use this one
really you should be doing all of this
right so I'm just going to try and treat
this question as if we just did all of
this okay off of the diagram I'm going
to go for this one okay so this is see
how what's going on is they've got
they've defined for you a spin them it's
like this is how fast we want you to go
around this corner we want you to go to
this speed so therefore we want to
design this so there's no friction for
that speed does that make sense okay so
let's go ahead and let's find my
theories I need to know with all these
pieces infection how do I feed them into
their okay now v VV VV what units is
being m/s is 120 km/h so let's quickly
convert V equals 120 kilometers is a
hundred and twenty thousand meters for
how many seconds 3600
30 minutes 60 seconds per minute so 3600
seconds okay um that's not going to come
out as a whole number okay so a hundred
on three meters per second yeah okay
there's a velocity and you have a look
at this what else am I going to need to
know radius that's just a thousand
meters and then gravity let's just go
with nine point eight okay can you go
ahead can you evaluate what it is okay
good okay we got there yeah so don't
forget to square don't forget to me in
the right mode etc okay cool it
wonderful I have an angle so if I want
to go at 120 + per hour this is the aim
of this is crispy and yes it is quite
shallow because yeah that's a pretty big
reader so far so good ok so now like
this is the perfect situation and what
I've got use this lateral force the
friction force is zero that's why I
haven't accounted for it that's why I
can use all this stuff okay but if this
is the angle and I'm not traveling at
this speed then there will be a force
under this way or that way okay now I
want you to think for a second right the
lateral force at the moment I've got
appointed positive direction out here
right so that's like skidding out like i
was showing on you on the diagram before
of instead of going around like that you
go we because there's not enough
friction okay so would i be traveling
faster to make a letter of horse up that
way or would i be traveling slower which
way am I supposed to adjust my velocity
okay so I'm trying to work out let's
just go with faster okay if I go faster
which way do you think friction force
will be pushing well friction force be
pushing that way or friction force
opportunity that way okay now what you
need to remember is freaking force is a
reaction force okay it's a reaction
force so what you've got is you're going
around the turn and if you're going too
fast friction force is trying to keep
you in but it's not enough it's not
enough ok so this Bank track see this
normal force to see where it's pointing
right
so it's kind of giving you a hand trying
to give you a hand right so therefore if
you're going too fast friction force is
going to be the thing that's pulling you
in okay so your your your tie isn't
going to screech okay because friction
force is like I don't go that way I'm
going to pull you this way okay so if
the velocity is greater than optimum
speed okay in my scheme where I put the
positive lateral force the positive side
ways positive friction force that's
going that way if you're going too fast
l is going to be negative do you see it
right itals try to hold you in trying to
hold you with all right now let's just
turn the table around if I'm good
grandma house behind the mule right and
she's like too fast okay so she slows
right down she's like I'd enjoy decays
an hour are you kidding I'm gonna run
over some people so she slows right down
so she's pottering along this Bank track
now thick think you're traveling alone
you're not going fast enough right which
way is friction force gonna go yeah well
your cars just going to go he's just
going to fall roll down the hill right
so friction force is trying to stop you
do that doing that it's a reaction force
right so if the boss is too slow then I
was going to be facing on the outside to
stop you rolling down the hill does that
make sense so this is trying to stop you
going wherever you're meant to be
wherever you're naturally tending toward
okay that's your tires job after all so
let's go with two speed let's get out
with this cost fifty percent so that's
180 k too narrow that's pretty quick
okay foregoing a hydrator who cares now
are what will be the friction force and
then lets up what's hard that the taste
of we heart that's 90 KC now that's
still pretty quick but it's slower than
the design speed okay so why not use
what will the friction force be if we go
at 180 okay so now what will the
friction for speed if you go
90 k is an hour and there's one more
piece of information you need apart from
speed I've got a radius already like
this situation I mean this situation
this angle think you're driving along
right there's you unlike a bicycle okay
and off you go around and then and then
right behind you there's a semi-trailer
pull them through right takes the same
turn same speed are you guys going to
have the same friction force no we mass
okay so just for the segment I'm going
to define mass to me 1217 kilos okay yes
approximately the weight of my car okay
this is uh yes sire I broke my scales at
home no I looked it up okay so good this
is the this is the mass of a
normal-sized small sedan okay uh without
many people in it okay that won't change
very much if I got in so let's go with
that number what does it turn to
somebody think they carefully think
carefully I'm gonna give you a one or
two minute head start you've already
you've already nutted out all of the
resolution of forces for the normal
force but you haven't touched this
lateral sideways friction force yet
you're going to need to resolve that too
and just like I did here we want to stay
stationary right we want them to uniform
circular motion how is everything going
to combine when you've got this third
force at plan why don't you get a head
start on me and then I'll show you my
solution